odyssey aura nor virus
I invite you so that I'm in an
interview
time is back the moment
hello what's up I'm talking to you sura
well I like to use presentation
for special moments but today I bring
my favorites those who have moments
after center the hip is part of
what is the new album of the virus you have
many special moments that my
children my family I am in the middle of my
wife of pitt dose has what it is to
live or the complete concept the
different planets the 42 the planet
nibiru in general he likes the  doors
gold white gold but like the world of
wine later with color and with different things I
wanted not to leave that in the
exception and this made it a sexual and
folk type kate a I love friend of mine for many
years today is here to do it as what
general concept for  that people,
as well as identify themselves, feel
that when I put my head here on
earth it is a photo I want to see how they are
made it has a meaning about an e  It's
a complete concept, that's what the virus says,
super fan of fixing each clock, it
has a moment, first we start with
the errors, ex-president, meaning,
because my wife and this one is mine, it's
like the couple itself, really, the
Pedregal neighborhood to my wife in 52.  It's fine
and it's like the couple says that she and
I for that reason because I have almost two watches
that are similar the only thing we can
keep from outside and other smaller
ones on the water and this is the bar
that I have the pear and jewelry box projects
He tells me which are the best
collections of watches. I always
tell them that he tells me what comes out and the
best collections, because he buys them.
This is a special edition of the role, it
is size 44, which is one of the
largest waiting for the  factory diamonds from the
factory and for the president
with the original diamond Roman eggs
I think it is not easy to
find
according to Hoyer that anyone the day
always Gómez
this is other roles of the most recent  s
that I have bought I bought it with the
colors of two boats that is Puerto
Rico and the Dominican Republic they are for me it
has the meaning of my blood of my
others of me and those of my generation it is of
the people who always supported me when
I wear it  I say about the clock of my flag
about this genre that the
Dominican Republic and Puerto Rico is my meaning
with the colors that they have that a red or
blue I have this tree is that they must have
been an inspiration and nicolas cage and to
see it but I had never seen it  it was
unique at that time I get so tired that I
close it and when I go to look for watches
I find that this watch is
for me it really has an inspiration
I really find it in a person
that in a while the giant of the world
has I can have it with me it's like
For me it is a legal privilege, a
genre of very few pieces, very few
collections, very expensive, and in
Nicolas Cage's factory there are always several, one
specific one, but the main one is his
person.  ality
[Music]
I have the rainbow this was what I
asked with another friend of mine colleague what
sandwich did we both buy on the same day at
the same time and we sort of decided that
this watch and we go to the channel what it was, well,
the real half what we were
really his dream achieved
because well not everyone can
buy it is as exclusive as
the taste of a good watch that awaits me they
will also compute to live some
colors and that is it was more fever and a
meaning of friendship that has the
terrain is the rainbow in a
very special edition of the wolves I think it is the
most exclusive piece the burn luís
soundview this is one of my
favorite watches as the passage of time
I like it a lot to exercise I
really like the color to combine them
what is it  unique with the mel of I really like
times of presenting what Jamaica is,
but for me it's a lot about color
and the brand I like a lot, it's the
carlos school the ritz I'm still alive just like I don't
pes  they
can exercise it wasn't like that
get a watch like it's a brand
that they can do all that get into the
water run all the extreme sports
two other times be for the good this
edition really is totally carbon
and not really if you take it you think it
seems  it's a lie because usain bolt doesn't have
any weight
I think u only
use it but I use it
[Applause]
and it's that I donned my first
billboard award as a new artist or
new revelation in a watch I bought it before always
as I like it  with the prizes I like it
as a gift this month I
bought it in the living no one would say it in
that internal world of new good and they
captured an extremely high price at that
moment in my career but I took the
risk because maybe they said it is  some
special moment I will always see it
with that meaning and first I became
the first prize 1,000 words and
this complete white gold submarine gerbolés is a signifier
used only twice
to a watch that I have as a collection and
in a few pieces in the world complete white gold
and it really has no
meaning this little because I do
n't use it and it is a total investment
because there are very few pieces of this and it
is more of a watch  of connection that
another thing without panic it is good only
one piece with for textile show you will not
find it anywhere it is one of
some and they have it blue it has a base
finish a phoenix in colors they
made a tiff edition to the
unsuspecting  I'll see what was crazy first
I want the richard mille the
williamson sapphire is very difficult to get we
have to go looking for them little by little we have to
find them
we are looking for nothing on the ipad to
make it clear that the back today
and for all those people  who
collect watch collections watches
is not so much the value it is so much the
cost what you have what you can have
but the meaning of each piece by
piece that has a meaning for
when it is ma  yor that you use it so much it has
that meaning make an investment in
turning on watches do not make investments
because the other I have the other you do not have and
what is that everything is with meaning and
with that passion that we always
do not know how to do slowly what is what
it costs but what does it mean